it's not all about money I think it's a
scapegoat we had more money we could
hire this or do this it's become
fashionable to say oh it's a waste it's
a cesspool the problem is in what
happened once the money got Camden I
think people often forget how poor the
city is there's just a sense of
hopelessness that this is just a cycle
that I'm stuck in there's not many
streets in Camden you can drive down
that you don't how is this houses in New
Jersey houses right next to a
Collingswood or a Cherry Hill or a hat
infield you can go on one Street and it
looks like there are 14 houses and 12
are abandoned and closed up Camden New
Jersey is the poorest small city in
America but it's also a case study in
how government programs have proven
tragically ineffective at ameliorating
poverty state and federal taxpayers have
spent hundreds of millions of dollars on
various revitalization projects in
Camden over the years but the money
never ended up where it was supposed to
and nothing changed by far the largest
initiative to combat poverty with
government largesse has been directed at
Camden's public schools New Jersey
spends about 60% more on public
education per pupil than the national
average or about $19,000 in 2013 in
Camden per pupil spending was more than
25 thousand dollars making it one of the
highest spending districts in the nation
and yet all that extra money hasn't
changed the fact that Camden schools are
among the worst in the state known for
their bismal test scores high rates of
in-school violence
dilapidated buildings and high dropout
rates the story of how Camden became one
of the nation's best funded and worse
performing school districts begins in
the early 1980s when a small nonprofit
called the education law center filed a
landmark lawsuit called Abbott V Burke
at the time poor cities in New Jersey
like Camden we're getting about 25
percent less funding for their schools
the New Jersey's more affluent suburbs
Rutgers law professor Paul Trachtenberg
was one of the legal architects of avid
Birk so he had the winners and the
losers and typically the winners were
white suburban students and the losers
were the growing number of black
students living in in cities and the
disparities in what was spent on their
education and in the quality of the
school buildings and the school programs
and the class size was dramatic it's not
all about money Saul Cooperman was the
state education commissioner under New
Jersey Governor Tom Kane and he fought
Abbott V Burke on the grounds of the
school districts in cities like Camden
were rife with mismanagement waste and
corruption schools were money pots so it
was patronage on a huge scale and also
contracts you could set up corporations
to go for contracts you could
subcontract that out and though I saw
some good people in urban schools ah
mostly I saw politicized problems at the
top but Trachtenberg along with Maryland
Moore Hauser a former nun and civil
rights activist who litigated avid fever
framed the issue in stark moral terms
more and more of these kids are
disadvantaged how can you not give the
kids money they didn't want to go in and
see what the exact problem was and was
it a money problem I don't want to make
this ad hominem but you've got in Tom
Kane and Saul Cooperman two white
suburban guys who knew pretty much zero
about urban education we've created this
kind of Mythology which is very handy
for white suburban Heights to say well
we don't want to send money to those
corrupt inefficient ineffective places
children of color are citizens just as
fully as are their counterparts in
wealthy suburbs there's no person I know
who doesn't believe that Maryland Moore
Hauser was a saint and there's no person
I know who doesn't think that the goal
of equalizing funding in the districts
wasn't the right one
pursue the problem is in what happened
once the money got there Saul Cooper
moons warnings would turn out to be
prophetic
after the abbot money started flowing
out of Trenton in the late 1990s the
state launched an ambitious school
construction program targeted at fixing
the dilapidated school buildings in
Camden and the other so-called abbot
districts and what we found was that
less than half of the proposed schools
got built and a billion dollars of money
got lost the audits of the of the
conditions afterwards were very clear
people were paying out their friends the
cost overruns were unbelievable they're
the same things that still go on jobs
and contracts jobs and contracts that's
money that doesn't go to kids
mismanagement and corruption also
continue to weigh on the day-to-day
operations in Camden and many of the
other Abbott districts a 2008 audit of
Camden's district office found a chaotic
management culture a lack of standard
accounting practices and questionable
use of state funds such as 13 million
dollars spent over two years on travel
expenses for school staffers to attend
education conferences the state Supreme
Court also mandated that New Jersey fund
universal preschool in Camden in the
other Abbott districts so that thing has
been good I think the problem is that
people sell pre-k as the answer to k12
dysfunction and if you don't fix k12 you
waste the gains of pre-k it's become
fashionable to say oh it's a waste it's
a cesspool its money down the rat hole
all these not very complimentary phrases
but the state is the ultimately
responsible actor for education so that
being the case to the extent there are
failures in the administration of
schools in the proper use of money it's
the state that's ultimately responsible
and that that's undeniable as a matter
of law it is easy to say that is the
state's responsibility because it just
absolves every district of their
complete and utter fiscal and
educational failure for kids over the
last 30 years
a lack of resource is not a problem I
actually despise that argument um I
think it's it's a scapegoat
we need more money if we had more money
we could hire this or do this it's just
a band-aid to the problem why not
address the real issue which is what's
broken right in front of you
Bridget Kusano Rosa is the principle of
freedom prep one of ten charter schools
in Camden just as the Abbott money
started to flow in the late 1990s New
Jersey's first charter schools began
opening and they've demonstrated that
it's possible to do an effective job of
educating kids from poor backgrounds
with significantly less money charters
get about 70% of the funding per pupil
as traditional public schools but
they're also more insulated from the
corrupting influence of politics for one
thing they have to pay for their school
buildings out of their own budgets
freedom prep is located on the fifth
floor of a hospital you find a way to
make it work you cut out things that are
incidentals that don't matter and
pushing a child to college if you put
the focus on your teachers and your
scholars education everything else you
can figure out is money important yes
the teachers must be well paid or you
can't recruit teachers to work in Camden
New Jersey City or Elizabeth but if
you're paying the teachers well and I
submit you look at urban salaries and
they are paid very very well as are the
principals and superintendents so that's
not a money issue there are no quick
generalizations and the proof of the
pudding is hasn't changed because of the
money my father
was a homeless drug addict before I get
from walking tall I wasn't supposed to
make it out I wasn't supposed to
graduate high school I wasn't supposed
to go to college
[Applause]